imaginons la situation suivante on
s'intéresse à un astronaute qui tombe à
l'intérieur d'un trou noir sphérique
autrement dit un trou noir de
schwarzschild
donc le trou noir de shark shield est
une sphère statique à l'intérieur de
laquelle se trouve un point une
singularité centrale et l'astronaute qui
va tomber dans le trou noir à un moment
on va franchir l'horizon des événements
et puis tomber inéluctablement vers la
singularité alors à partir de l'horizon
l'astronaute peut avoir de multiples
trajectoires différentes donc il peut
avoir des trajectoires plus ou moins
sinueuse vers le centre trajectoire
directe par exemple ou une trajectoire
qui tourne autour du trou noir autour du
centre mais l'astronaute n'a pas le
choix il est forcé de tomber en un temps
finis jusqu'au centre est ce qui va nous
intéresser dans cette vidéo c'est de
calculer la limite le temps maximal que
mais l'astronaute à atteindre le centre
pour résoudre ce problème on va utiliser
les coordonnées et la métrique de
schwarzschild et donc la métrique
s'écrit de cette façon des escarres et
l'intervalle d'espace-temps est égal à
moins c'est carré d'été carré facteur de
1 - rs sur air plus des airs carrés sur
1 - rs sur r + r carré fois défi au
carré est ici les coordonnées sont tes
airs et fi t est encore données
temporelles qui correspond au temps d'un
observateur très lointain donc on peut
imaginer une horloge sur porté par un
observateur très lointain tc le temps
entre guillemets que porte cet
observateur lointain r c'est une
coordonnées radial qui permet d'une
certaine façon de mesurer la distance
par rapport au centre par par la
singularité
ici l'accord donné de l'horizon en
particulier est notée rs c'est le rayon
de schwarzschild l'accord donné du
centre cr égal zéro et plus
l'observateur va tomber plus
l'astronaute tombe vers la singularité
plus à coordonner air diminue jusqu'à
atteindre 0 et enfin fille c'est
simplement un angle qui permet de
repérer l'astronaute autour de la
singularité
alors la première chose qu'on peut faire
pour résoudre ce problème c'est de
réaliser que l'astronaute effets de
matière et donc une loi entre guillemets
de l'espace temps c'est que tous les
objets de matières se déplace à la
vitesse de la lumière alors bien entendu
l'astronaute ne se déplace pas la
vitesse de la lumière dans l'espace mais
ils se déplacent à la vitesse de la
lumière dans l'espace temps donc il faut
imaginer que l'astronaute porte un temps
propre sa propre horloge on notera son
temps propre tôt et si nous intéresse
c'est le temps propres qu'ils mesurent
entre le moment où il franchit l'horizon
et le moment où il atteint la
singularité car évidemment vu de
l'extérieur on ne verra jamais
l'astronaute franchir l'horizon
donc comme l'astronaute se déplace à la
vitesse de la lumière dans
l'espace-temps
l'intervalle d'espace-temps qu'il
parcourt et ses carrés la vitesse de la
lumière
donc ici c'est l'intervalle au carré
donc la vitesse de la lumière au carré
fois des taux l'intervalle de temps
propre au carré car la distance qu'ils
parcourent dans l'espace temps c'est sa
vitesse fois le temps qui s'est écoulé
à lauris il faut rajouter un signe
négatif puisque on considère une
distance qui est temporel et si la
métrique la convention de metric qu'on
utilise c'est moins pour les intervalles
temporel et plus pour les intervalles de
type espace
donc cet intervalle d'espace-temps ici
est directement égal à moins c'est carré
des tocards et utp est le temps propre
que mesure l'astronaute
donc on a cette équation que - c'est
carré des tocards et est égal à tout ça
est ce qui nous intéresse c'est de
relier la variation radial de la
position de l'astronaute au fur et à
mesure qu'ils tombent à l'intervalle de
temps propre qu'il mesure est donc on va
essayer de relier ce dr à ceux des taux
donc pour faire ça on peut commencer par
/ des tocards et des deux côtés de
l'équation donc on obtient moins c'est
carré en divisant ici par des tocards et
est égal à moins c'est carré t poincaré
donc des points ici c'est d'été sur des
taux donc ici on a divisé
par des tocards et donc le dt carré
devient t poincaré
facteur de 1 - rs sur air
plus de la même façon on a r poincaré en
divisant dr carré par des tocards et sur
un moins rassuré
plus errecart et fit pontcarré
à partir d'ici on peut faire une
remarque assez intéressante c'est que
l'accord donné air que porte
l'astronaute et forcément inférieur à rs
en tout cas inférieur ou égal lorsqu'ils
se trouvent à l'intérieur du trou noir
et comme ce qui nous intéresse c'est le
temps propre entre le moment où il
rentre dans ton noir le moment il
atteint la singularité et bien tout du
long de la trajectoire et air sera
effectivement inférieur ou égal à rs
donc on peut tout de suite considéré qu'
air est inférieur ou égal à rs est donc
en particulier cette grandeur ici 1 -
errer sur air est négative puisque air
est plus petit que rs donc très sûr et
plus grand que l'un est donc tout ça est
plus petit que 0 donc ce qu'on va faire
c'est écrire directement ses grandeurs
en changeant leur signe puisqu'on veut
des grandeurs positive pour y voir plus
clair
ici on à rs sur r - 1 ici de la même
façon on a erré sur r - 1
donc maintenant on a des grandeurs qui
sont positives mais ça implique de
devoir changer les signes qui sont ici
et donc l'intervalle temporel le terme
temporelle de la métrique devient
positif et le terme spatiale de la
métrique devient négatif et c'est pour
ça qu'on entend parfois que le temps et
l'espace sainte et rechange dans un trou
noir puisque le terme spatiale en tout
cas le terme qui correspond à l'altitude
devient un terme négatif c'est-à-dire un
terme qui correspond en fait un
intervalle de type temps et c'est assez
logique puisque dans un trou noir on ne
peut que tomber vers le centre c'est à
dire que notre futur des sans forcément
en altitude et donc l'altitude mesure le
temps
alors une fois qu'on a fait ce
changement de convention pour changer
les signes on va pouvoir remarqué
quelque chose de très intéressant c'est
que si on passe ce r poincaré de l'autre
côté de l'équation est bien tous les
termes à droite de l'équation vont
devenir positif alors on va faire la
transformation et puis on va regarder ce
que ça donne r poincaré sur rs sur r20
qui devient positif puisque on le passe
à gauche de l'équation est égal on va
passer ce - c'est carré à droite donc il
devient positif qui est égal à ces
carrés plus sicav et des points carré et
raie sur et 1 - 1
plus vers carey fille poincaré et si
tous les termes qui sont à droite sont
positifs puisque on a vu que ce rs sur r
- 1 est positif et si on n'a que des
termes qui sont au carré donc forcément
positif or ce qui nous intéresse c'est
de connaître le temps est maximale de la
trajectoire entre l'horizon et le centre
du trou noir donc le temps exact que va
mettre l'astronaute entre ces deux
points dépend de sa trajectoire nous ce
qui nous intéresse c'est pas la valeur
qui dépend de sa trajectoire mais
uniquement une valeur maximale une
valeur limite et en particulier on va
voir que c'est la valeur qui est
engendrée lorsque l'astronaute ne fait
rien et tombe en ligne droite
pour avoir cette valeur limite du temps
pour maximiser le temps de l'astronaute
on veut minimiser sa vitesse de chute
c'est à dire minimiser le rythme auquel
son altitude varient et donc minimiser
la valeur absolue de r points ou encore
air point aucun
ici pour minimiser air poincaré il
suffit de trouver une borne pour cette
grandeur qui se trouve à droite et ici
les grandes heures thé point et fit
point on ne les connaît pas elles
dépendent en particulier de la
trajectoire de l'astronaute et donc on
peut considérer simplement qu'elles sont
plus grandes que 0 vu que elles sont
mises au carré et notre borne est tout
trouvé et reprend carrés sur et
réassureurs -1 et simplement plus grand
ou égal à ces carrés
donc on a sept bornes ici et on va
pouvoir passer ce terme emballe
dénominateur de l'autre côté en
multipliant des deux côtés on n'obtient
que air poincaré est supérieur ou égal à
ces carrés facteur de rs sur r - 1 alors
en autant ici que ce terme est positif
et donc on n'a pas changé le sens de
l'inégalité
alors maintenant on peut passer tout ça
à la racine carrée il faut faire bien
attention air point est négatif puisque
l'astronaute tombe donc son attitude
diminué au cours du temps et donc le
sens de l'inégalité change et en prenant
la racine carrée on prend la racine
négative
et on obtient cette inégalité
alors on a presque terminé il suffit de
se rappeler que air point c'est la
dérive et de r par rapport au temps
propre c'est dr sur des taux et donc en
particulier si on inverse tout cette
équation des taux sur des airs et plus
grand régal vu qu'on inverse il faut
changer le signe de l'inégalité à -1 sur
ses racines de errer sur r -
et cette équation c'est une équation qui
va nous permettre de résoudre le
problème puisque en intégrant tout ça on
va obtenir le temps propre de
l'astronaute quand il est maximisée lors
de sa chute
donc pour intégrer tout ça on va
multiplier des deux côtés par dr donc à
gauche on obtient des taux
et à droite dr et s'il faut faire très
attention
dr et là variations d'altitude de
l'astronaute et comme l'astronaute tombe
vers le centre du trou noir se dr est
négatif et donc on a multiplié par
quelque chose de négatif
ce qui signifie qu'on doit inverser le
sens de l'inégalité donc le temps propre
la variation temps propre est inférieure
à une certaines bornes cette borne est
positive puisque - dr dr n étant négatif
- dr est positif et donc le temps propre
et maximiser par cette grandeur est donc
maintenant ce qu'on veut faire c'est
intégré simplement des deux côtés pour
obtenir la valeur totale du temps entre
l'instant initial où l'astronaute se
situe à et régale rs et l'instant finale
où l'astronaute situe à air égal zéro
donc ici on intègre entre air égale rs
l'horizon et r égal 0 la singularité
lorsqu'on peut faire c'est inversé
l'ordre des bornes vu qu'on voit que
l'ordre ici et des croissants donc on
peu plus plus naturellement partir de
zéro et intégrer jusqu'à rs
et lorsqu on inverse les bornes il faut
changer le signe et ça nous arrange
comme ça on obtient bien une valeur
positive tandis que de l'autre côté
l'intégrale du temps propre c'est
simplement le temps maximal qu on notera
grant est la valeur qui nous intéresse
et qu'on essaye de calculer dans cette
vidéo
donc si c'est le temps maximal ici plus
besoin d'écrire l'inégalité le temps
maximal est égal à 7 intégrale
bon eh bien maintenant il suffit de
calculer cette intégrale alors pour
calculer cette intégrale on va commencer
par faire un changement de variables qui
paraît assez naturel alors je vais
réécrire l'intégrale rapidement
et on voit que la seule variable qui
intervient ici dans le dénominateur
c'est air / s en particulier on voit que
le rs ici intervient un peu comme un
facteur d'échelle et que l'intégrale ne
dépend pas de ce facteur d'échelle elle
dépend de r / aise
donc on peut poser une nouvelle variable
qu'on appellera une qui sera défini
comme air / s du coup air est égale à
une fois rs et dr est égal à rs x d'élus
donc ici dr on peut le remplacer par rs
wade lui
le rs sur air devient simplement un sur
rue
et il faut faire attention à bien changé
les bornes donc lorsque air égal 0 on a
bien eu égard 0 mais lorsque air est
égal à rs on a eu égal 1
donc la borne supérieure devient un
et si on a obtenu un résultat qui est
assez intéressant puisque rs essais sont
deux constantes dont complet sortir de
l'intégrale et on obtient rs sur ces x
une intégrale qui ne dépend plus d'aucun
paramètres du problème c'est une
intégrale usuels qu'on peut calculer
alors pour calculer cette intégrale on
va utiliser une astuce qui est difficile
à trouver quand on n'a pas l'habitude de
ce genre d'intégrale en gros l'intuition
qui se trouve derrière cette astuce
derrière ce changement de variables
c'est qu'on observe une racine carrée de
quelque chose - 1 ou 2 1 - quelque chose
est généralement ceux ci rappellent les
fonctions trigonométriques puisqu'on a
la propriété que qu'oscar et plus si le
carré est égal à 1 et donc en
particulier que cos est égale à la
racine de 1 - sin carré et vice versa on
voit ici une forme qui rappelle un peu
ce qu'on a dans notre intégral
lors l'idée la plus naturelle et de
poser le changement de variables suivant
on va écrire que huet égal aux sinus au
carré deux états
alors pourquoi sinus carré bien parce
qu'ici on a pu à la puissance 1 et on
aimerait une identité trigonométriques
et donc on aimerait ainsi l'us carré ou
un caussinus carré
et pourquoi sinus et bien tout
simplement parce que ici on intègre
entre 0 et 1 et le sinus entre 0 et 1 et
une fonction un objectif alors c'est le
cas aussi pour le cosinus carré mais ici
c'est tout simplement un choix
arbitraire
alors ici j'ai tracé le sinus mais on
intègre avec un sinus carré donc aux
sinus carrés à peu près cette forme là
entre 0 et 1 et donc lorsque le thymus
vos héros on hâte état si cet état ici
ses sinus l'état au carré on hâte état
qui est égal à zéro lorsque le sinus
carré vaut 1 on hâte état qui est égale
appuyé sur deux
sur le cercle trigonométriques on
intègre entre teta égal zéro donc ici
jusque tête à galp et sûrs d'eux ici
lorsqu on différencie cette équation ce
changement de variables on n'obtient que
des u est égal à 2 sinus l'état co-signe
cet état des états ça c'est la dérive et
du sinus carré
donc on peut remplacer tout ça dans
notre intégral alors tout ceci est égal
toujours à perez sur ces facteurs de
l'intégrale de 0 api sur deux cette
fois-ci de de sinus teta caussinus teta
des états sur la racine carrée de un
sursis jusqu'à rennes est à -1
alors là ça peut faire très peur on a
une expression qui semble a priori
beaucoup plus complexe que ce qu'on a au
dessus mais on n'a pas fait ce
changement de variables pour rien c'est
parce qu'il va nous simplifier la tâche
ici on va observer une identité
trigonométriques
alors le moins un qui est ici on va
pouvoir le mettre sur le même
dénominateur quand on multiplie par
sinus carré et on obtient au numérateur
1 - sinus carré et ça lorsqu'on connaît
nos formules trigonométriques on
identifie que c'est simplement caussinus
carré de tête à
et c'est là que la magie opère le
cosinus carré ici bien à la racine
devient un caussinus normal alors ici on
a bien fait attention on est bien dans
le quart de cercle où le cosinus est
positif et donc pas besoin de mettre un
signe négatif pour le cosinus il est
bien positif il va bien annulé le
cosinus qui se trouve au numérateur
quant aux sinus carré qui se trouve au
dénominateur ici eh bien il va
simplement venir multipliez le sinus qui
se trouve au numérateur et on obtient
ainsi nuss locales et donc si je réécris
cette intégrale on obtient en sortant le
2 2 rs sur ces facteurs de l'intégrale
de 0 api sur deux de sinus carretta
d'état
et là on a presque terminé le sinus
carré de teta donc c'est une autre
formule trigonométriques le sinus
carette et à ses 1 - le cosinus de deux
états sur deux donc ça c'est une formule
qui est qu'il est important de connaître
lorsqu'on fait des intégrales de ce type
avec des sinus carré ou des caussinus
carré et donc en particulier le cosinus
de deux états ici lorsqu'on va
l'intégrer donc caussinus de teta on
l'aurait intégré entre 0 et puis sur
deux mais caussinus de deux états c'est
comme si on intègre et un caussinus
entre 0 épi est donc en fait le cosinus
ici est positif et le cosinus ici est
négatif donc chaque valeur positive du
caussinus va être annulée par une valeur
de l'autre côté ce caussinus là
lorsqu'on intègre et anti symétrique et
donc son intégrale va simplement
s'annuler est donc d'intégrer un sinus
carré entre ces bornes c'est comme si on
intègre est simplement un demi
et l'intégrale de 1/2 entre 0 épissures
de cépie sur quatre donc toute cette
intégrale ici est égale simplement à 2
rs sur ces fois puis sur quatre c'est à
dire pis rs sur 2 c
on a obtenu notre résultat la valeur de
cette intégrale c'est pis rs sur 2 c on
pourrait s'arrêter là mais on sait que
le rayon de shark shield et exprimable
en fonction de la masse du trou noir
rs est égale à deux fois gm sur ces
carrés ça c'est une équation qui est
assez fondamentale lorsqu'on s'intéresse
aux trous noirs de schwarzschild
m étant la masse du trou noir
j'ai étant la constante de gravitation
universelle de newton et c'est toujours
la vitesse de la lumière
donc pour terminer on peut écrire que t
max est égale donc ici on remplace rs
par ceux de gm sur ces carrés les deux
ça nul et on obtient pis gm sur ces
cubes
cette formule c'est la formule finale
qui nous donne le temps maximal de chute
entre l'horizon est le point central
d'un trou noir de schwarzschild